Let's go next to our caller from the six five
zero area code.
Who's calling today from six five zero?
Yes, load them.
Yes, it is.
Yes, this is well, I'm calling from Washington,
D.C..
I was mostly calling to talk a little bit
about the alternatives or to the sort of formal
policing systems that we have.
We're talking about defunding the police.
Right.
And doing so.
Do you believe that that would maybe create
a lot more informal conflict resolution that
would occur like nationally communities, sort
of a lie or not?
Because I know that in more developed countries,
they sort of run into this problem where,
you know, crimes are committed constantly,
but people don't have any criminal histories
officially because the police just aren't
involved in a lot of criminal aspects of like
that.
Right.
And how that works out in terms of doing so,
that gives like a lot of employers all over
the city, probably a lot of confidence to
that, higher trust, things like that.
It's tends to be a social fabric.
I just want to see she did speak about that
in informal conflict resolution can be good
or bad depending on the context.
Right.
You do have places where things like burglaries
or physical crimes are dealt with by families
or groups or mob like entities essentially
dealing with it by themselves.
And I don't know that that's really any better
than having police involvement in other cases
for other types of disputes.
You can certainly support infrastructure for
resolution that doesn't involve police.
But what is important to understand is a lot
of these conflicts, I guess, is the word we're
using.
A lot of these conflicts aren't really resolved
by police in the sense that police may be
involved initially.
But really, it's the court system that ultimately
is adjudicating right, either through plea
deals, states attorneys and prosecutors, et
cetera.
So I think it's also important when we think
about, you know, defund versus reform.
And, you know, we've already I've already
had that conversation a bunch of times this
week.
We also want to not pretend that the police
are more involved in the resolution of a lot
of these things now, because really the police,
you know, in a burglary, police are showing
up and they're eventually it's assigned to
a detective and an investigation is done.
But eventually, really the resolution and
the disposition is determined by the court
system.
And that's a different system.
It's part of a broader law enforcement apparatus,
in a sense, but it's a different system.
So I think it's important we don't want to
overstate or understate where police are and
are not involved, if that makes sense.
Well, that has a lot to do with civil war
type of law.
Just a difference of being sued to get somebody
who sue feels hard to get away.
But no question.
OK.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
zero eight area code.
Who's calling today from nine zero eight?
Hi, is this me?
Yes, it is.
Who's this?
Oh, my name is free.
I'm from New Jersey.
And so it's like such a pleasure to be able
to talk to you.
I really love your show.
And I think like a year now.
Wow.
Thank you.
The pleasure is mine.
Yeah, I guess like it has a very general,
broad question for you, sir.
And I wanted to know what.
Sorry, I just want to know what were the biggest
inspiration for, like your progressive outlook,
like regarding social and economic policies?
I have no idea how to quantify that.
I mean, you know that my views today are built
on essentially 20 years of following politics
and reading economics, history, philosophy.
I really couldn't say my biggest inspirations.
I mean, you know, it's built on reading everything
from, you know, 18th century philosophy, an
ancient Greek philosophy to Angus Dayton's
book on economic well-being written a few
years ago.
You know, it's really, really tough.
And I wouldn't I at this point, it's hard
to say any one or another inspiration.
I mean, I think the framework I'm operating
under overall is I would be what I consider
a left libertarian social Democrat in that
I want a compelling reason to have government
involved in endeavors.
And there are compelling reasons to have government
involved in health care and education, not
so much in manufacturing airplanes, but the
regulatory responsibility of government is
huge there.
I want people to have as much freedom for
self-determination as possible, and government
should be very involved in setting those conditions,
but not going beyond that in terms of determining
what jobs people should have or the like.
I mean, it's it's an interesting question
because it goes to my general framework.
And at this point, I've been following all
this stuff for so long, free head, that it's
like I couldn't name like three people that
have mostly inspired me, if that makes sense.
OK.
Yeah, I was just wondering, because I actually
majored in economics and marketing and my
undergraduate money is money.
I always feel like this kind of loan, like
progressive voice are like having this, like,
progressive outlet.
I guess among my peers in finance, like, I
guess I'm more interested in learning more
about, like economic policy, whether like
whether it be progressive or more conservative
to like, I guess get a better feel for how
to get a better feel for my understanding
of how I actually want the government to function.
And yeah, I mean, I think the problem with
a lot of economics departments in the US is
that they teach a really narrow range of stuff.
I mean, I've said before, I have no problem
with neoclassical economics being taught.
And it's important to understand that framework.
But when I went to the undergraduate University
of Massachusetts, I tried socialist.
Richard Wolf was one of my professors and
I learned Marxian economics and game theory.
And I got into behavioral economics personally
after I graduated.
And it's most economics programs are teaching
far too narrow a scope of material.
And it sounds like that's sort of what you're
realizing.
Yeah, it's like it's like a huge issue, like
I take environmental economics, like an upper
level economics elective actually interact
with university.
And I notice that a lot of the framework is
dealing with neoclassical theory and how I
was just wondering how a little bit limited
it is and dealing with negative externalities
arising from like things like pollution or
like companies being responsible for like
waste management or things like of that nature.
Yeah, I mean, neoclassical economics and market
theory fails to deal with a fails to appropriately
deal with externalities.
I'm actually reading that none of the concepts
are new, but it's an interesting book.
I'm reading Naked Economics by Wheelin is
his last name.
I believe he teaches at Dartmouth.
I forget his first name and it has an entire
chapter devoted to how you need government
involved in markets, because without it, the
negative externalities are dealt with only
in that they are passed along to somebody
else.
And your your analysis is exactly right.
All right.
I guess those are my only questions.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
You're like a huge inspiration for me because
you.
Thank you.
You like kind of your man, my progressive
politics.
And.
The reality is I can defend a little bit easier.
So I truly appreciate your voice of reason.
Have a good day.
Okay.
You too.
I so appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.